[Applaudissements]
que je vous reçois chez moi avec des
amis et toute la famille et mes enfants
regarde j'ai du pain et tout j'ai tout
préparément vous êtes venu chez moi
d'abord moi j'ai pas besoin de chaque
coup pour vivre je connais des amis qui
ont des châteaux qui ont des pavillons
qui ont des châteaux moi c'est pas la
fortune qui me faut c'est le respect
mutuel si vous voulez pas me respecter
c'est pas grave Guillaume je m'en vais
je ne suis pas entrepris moi je veux
être respect pour moi maintenant je
prends mes initiatives en tant que père
mais moi j'aime tes fesses
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vrai que ce piège on s'est dit
voilà on pouvait pas le diffuser sur
site vous allez voir après avoir bien
énervé Eugène en lui manquant de
respirer à propos de sa fille ça
commence à partir en sucette totale
après seulement 15 minutes de Franck
pardon
ça manque de respect que vous faites là
vous voulez que ce soit plaquer c'est
tout vous voulez ça hein non non est-ce
que vous me connaissez
oh non je vais me calmer je me calme toi
en fait assis-toi calme-toi
je suis là je
pas besoin de péter moi je vais être
tranquille avec ce qui se passe Jeanne
c'est pas
ok ok
de mes enfants ok ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première action moi j'avais
encore normalement six heures de piège
je me suis dit voilà je vais mourir tout
de suite et du coup je pouvais pas te
dérouler du tout et Eugène était déjà
très chaud alors c'était le début
c'était le début voilà donc là je me dis
je sais pas comment je vais faire pour
arriver jusqu'au bout et je m'attendais
à ce qui ce qui s'énerve parce que
Tiphaine sa fille nous avait dit qu'il
avait du tempérament mais là ouais il
nous a bien servi
et ça va être de plus en plus compliqué
au fil du piège en fait et c'est la
première fois qu'on a quelqu'un de aussi
explosif d'un coup j'étais à 20 minutes
ou à peu près alors c'est vrai qu'on a
pris l'addition de palp diffuser sur C8
c'est vrai qu'on a on n'a pas pu le
mettre à l'antenne parce que bah voilà
là c'est qu'un échantillon
mais c'est vrai que bah tu connais les
le CSA et
l'arcom la fabrique et du coup il y a
des règles après je sais pas toi je sais
pas ce que tu en dis si tu penses que ça
aurait pu être
franchement oui moi je l'aurais diffusé
moi je l'aurais diffusé sur C8
qui sont compliquées et du coup la C8 on
a fait le choix avec ces deux pas voilà
de pas passer ça à l'antenne alors Lyon
je suis pas programmateur
parce que déjà ça fait à ce moment-là ça
fait plusieurs mois qu'on travaille
dessus ça coûte on a déjà raté une
première fois avec une première fille
qui a pas pu faire le piège au final du
coup c'est des mois de travail et du
coup quand on est là-dedans on se dit on
va pas on va pas moi j'ai dans ma tête
c'est je me dis jamais je vais arrêter
je me dis comment je redescends pour
qu'il reste c'est surtout ça je me dis
là il y a un fusible en face je peux pas
les voir le producteur
je suis encore
foiré je n'ai pas le prendre parce que
on a dû arrêter et je suis le mois
d'août que de non non mais du coup je
continue faut voir comment je vais me
radoucir je vais essayer de jouer sur la
compassion de jeunes après je vais même
à un moment donné on me voit je m'assois
dans l'herbe je fais semblant
du producteur le producteur celui qui
paye l'édition le programme oui oui vous
le connaissez bien le producteur
alors moi j'aide non non je t'ai déjà
fait chier y dit la vérité franchement
pas beaucoup franchement
[Applaudissements]
un peu parce qu'on est long à arriver à
faire des pièces combien de temps pour
préparer ça en fait alors vous avez vu
sur en mai on a fait un piège sur C8 qui
a été diffusé en mai c'était
l'aboutissement mais ça c'était la
première tentative après on l'a raté
encore trois fois pour arriver à celui
de mai donc celui-là c'était là donc au
final on a passé un an et demi et ça
c'est la première tentative qui a été
sur Youtube parce que télé ce n'était
pas défini c'est-à-dire que le
producteur a perdu de l'argent sur le
programme le premier Cyril
[Rires]
non parce qu'en fait on a une enveloppe
et on doit on doit livrer
la masse ça se voit pas tu vois
alors la situation grec devient si
incontrôlable très vite Eugène euh bah
il devient fou et c'est normal il en a
marre que tu me parles mal de sa fille
que tu es que tu sois un mec dégueulasse
il veut vraiment se taper avec toi ils
vont découdre il sera avec nous dans un
instant Eugène juste après cette
expérience
non non non non moi je veux être gentil
avec tes fans tu n'es pas j'écris avec
moi et je suis désolé
non pardon
Guigui ça se dit pas je sais pas ce que
j'ai fait de mal je sais pas ce que j'ai
fait
non mais je suis d'accord avec eux
je voulais bien vous recevoir
peut-être excuse-moi jeune
toi en fait on peut écrire c'est
elle est énervé
de trucs qu'on s'est disparu
merci
à Brigitte et merci à Tiphaine la copine
de Guillaume dans le piège alors pour et
bien expliquer
Tiphaine et vous avez piégé les deux ou
voilà donc tous les deux bien sûr tu es
cité ça s'accomplisse tu as dit oui tout
de suite bah en fait elle a envoyé une
candidature pour que ses parents parce
qu'on cherchait les parents à piéger
pour ce programme et donc tu as envoyé
ta postuler et tu as plutôt bien vendu
tes PARENTS tu savais que tu savais que
ton père allait s'énerver comme ça ou
pas franchement non je pensais pas après
comme j'ai dit à Guillaume je lui ai dit
non je pense pas qu'il ira jusqu'à te
frapper je pense pas c'est vrai qu'elle
nous a dit ça et bah il a voulu me
frapper au bout de 15 minutes
juste un moment où grec tu te dis
comment je vais tenir plusieurs heures
je crois que j'ai encore un peu sur le
choc est beaucoup trop d'énergie
vous l'aviez tourné quand c'était un an
je crois qu'il y a un an et tu vois ils
ont encore plus blairer encore ça c'est
pas remis là eugène est beaucoup trop
vénère du coup tu tentes de calmer le
jeu regarde je sais pas comment on va
les calmer là vraiment c'est pas
possible bon tu fais le fun tu es mort
non mais c'est drôle mais c'est drôle
qu'à moitié j'ai jamais vu une réaction
pareil et qui était parti sur quel sujet
pour les mecs comme ça
depuis le début il retenait au fond de
lui et là il a il a câbler parce que
c'est le tu vois ça ça l'a fait il faut
qu'il revienne en fait faut arriver à
les faire j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un comme
ça mais attends il avait pété la
bouteille et tout ah ouais ouais nous à
mon avis il vaut mieux qu'on se fasse
petit et moi je suis là et je dis plus
rien limite il faut espérer qu'elle
arrive à les ramener là viens faut que
tu t'excuses je pense eh Kevin mon père
il s'est grave embrouillé avec Guillaume
et genre en mode tout à l'heure il
voulait le frapper etc je sais pas
essaie de voir avec lui
tu es pas combien d'euros il est là il
casse les trucs chez les gens après il y
a personne qui va payer de caution en
fait
non non je dis que je suis désolé
mais je sais pas en fait il veut frapper
il veut frapper Guillaume parce que le
téléphone je sais pas appelle-moi me
chercher rappelle-moi
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas
Eugène t'avais vraiment envie de le
défoncer
je pense pas je ne sais pas dans mes tu
as pété un câble oui j'ai pété j'ai pété
un petit peu oui c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui t'a fait qu'est-ce qui t'a
fait monter en pression
non c'était bon manque de respect bon
manque de respect c'est pas simple
c'est sûr Brigitte toi tu bouges pas
calme tu es calme toi tranquille zen
[Musique]
parce que je savais qu'il était énervé
donc moi aussi je devais pas t'énerver
aussi je te dis là tu vas rajouter la
tension
de tempérer jeune et c'est comment c'est
la voix de la sagesse ta maman qui la
voit la sagesse dans le couple c'est ça
tu as eu peur un moment qui fait nous
pas un moment on va un peu courir
il veut partir et tout mais justement
j'avais que ça pour me sauver parce que
alors après avoir réussi à le convaincre
de revenir et d'avoir calmer sur entre
guillemets c'est le coup de massue tu en
rajoutes une couche on lui annonçant
qu'elle est enceinte
j'ai dit que je l'ai mis enceinte c'est
qui c'est moi le King j'ai mis dans les
mail j'ai mis dans le mail aïe aïe aïe
il a annoncé c'est moi le bonhomme
bah ouais je la mets enceinte
de très vieille pas de sa vue assis-toi
mais pourquoi punaise
[Musique]
non je veux pas viens viens
mais pourquoi je voudrais me taper moi
je veux pas me taper avec toi jeune tu
es mon beau-père mais j'ai ta fille qui
est mort allez on sort de moi viens pas
chez moi viens pas chez moi parce que ça
va saigner plus jamais dans ma vie notre
fille je vais le chien jusqu'à ce que la
mort le sépare finalement c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle alors on va partir en
vacances tous ensemble on va faire
[Applaudissements]
un petit un petit un petit touche quoi
c'est ça
beaucoup de messages là depuis hier soir
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
est en voient des messages oui il y a
beaucoup de gens qui m'envoient un
message qui m'appelle bon qui m'appelle
pour ça et parce que le nombre de gens
qui regardent parce que ça tombait pas
avoir ça les fait rire quand ils t'ont
dit que c'était une caméra cachée après
tu t'es soulagé
caméra cachée peut-être que je me serais
pris une autre façon
il a super bien réagi hein
c'était plus le même Eugène
dans la régie il était trop content
ouais ça c'est super bien fini en fait
c'est ça aussi qui fait que une caméra
cachée est réussie c'est quand à la fin
la personne piégée le prend bien parce
que si c'est juste pour faire vivre un
Salaman et qu'après ça se passe mal
c'est pas intéressant à la fin j'avais
Brigitte sans redescendus ils ont adoré
c'était trop c'était ça c'est fini dans
la bonne humeur franchement c'est le
meilleur prank de Greg Guillotin et ce
qui est très fort c'est que d'habitude
dans les caméras cachées le piéger pète
les plombs juste avant la révélation et
là dès le début Eugène il part en quart
de tour donc en toute la caméra cachée
pendant 1h30 Greg il marche sur des œufs
et là j'ai l'impression que c'est la
première fois que tu as eu vraiment peur
je vais pas spoiler mais un moment tu
caches même des objets dans la pièce
faut pas que ça dérape ouais j'ai passé
mon temps en fait je suis même à un
moment donné sorti de mon personnage
c'est à dire qu'à un moment je devais
tellement adoucir les choses que c'était
plus le MC Guillaume que j'avais prévu
dans le piège parce que j'avais plus
aucune façon de canaliser jeune qui
croyait en plus que le portail était
fermé alors qui était ouvert à la fin il
va chercher la police mais bon ça c'est
après mais du coup moi je voulais juste
qu'on finisse le piège et qu'au moins ça
puisse se terminer bien et tout et c'est
la première fois que ça part aussi après
il y avait j'ai déjà eu peur le géranger
à l'avantagne voilà il y avait déjà eu
quelques antécédents mais là c'est vrai
que c'était là où j'ai le plus peur bah
c'est pour ça que je cours façon le but
c'est pas que ça ça finisse mal une
caméra cachée c'est quand même violence
véritable moi donc je m'éloigne dès que
je vois que j'aime commence à à courir
quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'il va toujours me
frapper
ça va mieux maintenant oui oui
[Rires]
il y a vraiment des trucs de ouf dans
cette caméra cachée c'est une des plus
fort vraiment je vous invite vraiment à
aller sur la chaîne Youtube de Greg pour
voir la suite et qu'est-ce qui devient
Louis Louis Vignac bah écoute on a des
projets ensemble pour wevegnac
incroyable vous connaissez son
personnage
ça va ça ouais on aimerait bien
travailler sur un film il y aimerait
bien stagiaire on va le faire voilà donc
voilà j'ai appris ça aujourd'hui voilà
donc merci Cyril mais on a rien fait
avec impatience c'est voilà c'était
incroyable en tout cas mon gregistrer
normalement qui revient bientôt voilà
il en fait pas beaucoup parce que c'est
des bosseurs avec David de fou et c'est
vrai que je le dis il a dit tout à
l'heure je suis un peu impatient
j'aimerais qu'il en fasse encore plus
mais il faut pas ils sont tellement
perfectionniste
parce qu'en fait on mène le plus long
c'est pas les tournages chez les
enquêtes qu'on mène avant pour être à
chaque fois qu'on s'expose à la télé
après moi je suis toujours content de
venir là mais on sait donc là par
exemple aujourd'hui on a prévenu les
complices qui voulaient piéger les gens
parce qu'on a déjà repéré tous les
prochains piégés et donc on a prévenu le
complet en disant surtout qui regarde
pas TPMP désolé pour l'audience
pardon tu es en train de me plomber les
couilles toi
Brigitte comment tu t'es senti toi tu as
eu peur pour pour jeune que j'aime
vraiment
peur j'avais eu vraiment peur tu savais
qu'il était d'habitude il n'est pas
comme ça mais moi c'était jamais énervé
comme ça tu l'avais jamais vu autant
énervé jamais
mon jeune ça va mieux tu étais plus
énervé depuis que personne non non non
non non non en plus tu as l'air hyper
calme toi
tu as tout donné avec lui quoi
merci en tout cas d'être venu il y a un
truc aussi parce que tu peux confirmer
mais tu me disais dès le départ que tes
parents ils voulaient pas venir parce
que en fait dans ta famille l'idée enfin
dans la tradition congolaise en fait
l'idée normalement c'est que c'est le
c'est le le jeune homme qui vient se
présenter aux parents c'est un peu
normales
j'ai jamais vu un mec qui dit bah tu
viens
voilà il est un peu contrarié
direct euh
c'est un amour de mec en plus vraiment
je te dis c'est un amour de mec
extrêmement
amoureuse de lui non
il y avait pas assez de temps bon bah
très bien merci